Through this lesson, I'm sure you have
a good understanding and appreciation for the hard
work in the implementation of an operating
system on a shared memory multiprocessor that ensures
capability of the basic mechanisms like synchronization,
communication, and scheduling. And this is not done
just once. It has to be done a new, for every new parallel architecture that
comes to market that has a vastly different
memory hierarchy compared to its predecessors. Can we
reduce the pin point of individually optimizing every
operating system that runs on a multi-processor? Now
what about device drivers, that form a big part of the code base of an operating
system? Do we have to reimplement them for
every flavor of operating systems that runs on a
new machine? Can we leverage third party device
drivers from the OEM's to reduce the pain point?